[Musique]
à
madame hilary vienne assistant familial
le bras panon
mais ce que disait madame il à
l'adoption
vous allez encore trop jeune une place
en fonction mais où va travail quand
seront en âge d'avoir adopté novateur
n'a dit oui c'est comme ça recommence je
travaillais instinct maternel est quand
même de l'adopter les dieux oui oui
d'adopter les deux ans 83 le métier là
est et reste mal par rapport à mon jeune
âge me l'a commencée travail avec les
enfants
et puis avons travaillé moi mais
maintenant mon petit fois et bâtisseur
tout le monde y penser qu'on est
désolant c'est l'amour et tout le monde
y pense et c'était mes enfants veulent
des enfants n'a été placé chez moi il
faisait 5 ans 6 ans 3 ans et
voilà l'été maternelle et jusqu'à
maintenant mm utilisons appareils
et puis même il discute avec my comme
madden l'éducation des enfants des
dolmens appareils tous les enfants
placés ici appelé romane fayard dati ton
papa ppa oui oui il fait partie de la
famille n'a pas travaillé pour devenir
riche mais mal à rendre les enfants
heureux fois ce moment était fier mon
métier oui
allez mon avenir maintenant ses voyages
et occupe mes petits-enfants comme la
semaine beaucoup celle des hommes et non
me mets à profiter un peu de la
ministère et le soir quand même une idée
tout cela à l'homme fidh l'année joly le
départ est devenu dont la fina
biturbines habitués
d'habitude ma continue c'est à premiers
mois comme ça même